- Un remède de cheval pour
freiner l'inflation galopante.
La Banque du Canada fait passer
son taux directeur à 2,5 %,
une hausse de 1 point,
du jamais vu en près de 25 ans.
TIFF MACKLEM, gouverneur
de la Banque du Canada
- L'inflation est trop élevée
et plus de gens ont peur
que cette situation continue.
On ne peut pas laisser ça
arriver.
- Alors qu'elle prévoit que
l'inflation va demeurer autour
de 8 % au cours des prochains
mois, la banque centrale
veut donner un coup de barre.
Les pressions inflationnistes
proviennent de plus en plus
du marché intérieuande
en biens et services dépasse
l'offre, ce qui fait grimper les
prix. L'économie surchauffe.
- Ce qui a commencé comme
une inflation mondiale causée
par les prix élevés de l'énergie
et des biens est en train
de se généraliser au Canada.
JIMMY JEAN, économAN, économAN,f
et stratège Mouvement Desjardins
- La Banque du Canada est en
mode sauve-qui-peut pour établir
son autorité, sa crédibilité
en matière de ciblage
de l'infde l'infde l'infde l'in.
- Alors que l'on craint
qu'une spirale inflationniste
s'installe, l'économiste
Jimmy Jean se dit d'accord avec
la hausse de 1 point décrétée
aujourd'hui.
- Ce qu'on veut faire, c'est
vraime les ménages
et les entreprises quant au fait
qu'on est très agressif
et qu'on va éventuellement
avoir le dessus.
- C'est la quatrième hausse
du taux directeur depuis mars.
Ceux qui ont des prêts
hypothécaires à taux variable
sont directement tectement tect.
Et selonage,
les hausses de taux ont déjà
poussé certains acheteurs
hors du marché immobilier.
MARC LEFRANÇOIS, courtier imm.
Royal LePage Tendance
- L'acquéreur typiéreur typiéret
attaquer aussi par l'inflation.
Donc t'sais, il y a son coût
d'acquisition qui augmente,
l'inflation vient attaquer son
panier d'épicerie, ses moyens
de transde transde transde tran.
- Personnellement, je n'ai pas
encore acheté, mais j'allais
le faire cette année. C'est sûr
que maintenant, je vais aller
réfléchilus.
- Ceux qui ont des hypothèques,
des grosses hypothèques,
ça va être vraimele,
je trouve.
- Avec toute l'inflation
qu'il y a partout, il faut
contrô la masse
monétaire. On peut pas laisser
ça se développer à l'infini.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
- On va être là pour
diens, on est là
avec de l'aide aux familles, on
est là avec de l'aide aux aînés.
- La Banque du Canada estime que
le taux directeur devra grimper
encore davantage pour endiguerlt
que sa marge de manoeuvre
est de plus en plus petite
pour accomplir cette tâche
sans trop perturber l'économie
canadienne, alors que certains
craignent une récession.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-C